The Joe Rogan experience now,
how often do you practice?
Do you practices outside of hypnosis?
Is there like some things you
concentrate on or meditate on? Yeah,
so I do my best to just,
it's kind, Kinda like,
the weird thing about me is fighting is
something that is just kind of happened
by accident, but it's caused
me to search for so much peace,
like inner peace because of everything
that I go through emotionally being a
fighter. So going from this,
I know Shab told you about it,
but going from this kid who was just
like super overweight my whole life,
never fit in with anybody, I was always
just like this introverted, Gothic,
weird kid that nobody, you
know, nobody ever talked to,
didn't ever even want it to fight. Oh,
I've always been non confrontational.
But somewhere in the journey
of becoming a fighter,
I was like, ah, this is cool,
but I need to find more
peace because this is like,
it's bringing up way too much,
just like just way too much. My,
of my anger kind of like, you know,
from everything that I held onto.
So, uh, practice meditation,
a lot of meditation. I read a lot of
different, I'll study different religions,
whatever, wherever on that.
Um, all just to find peace.
Peaceman how confrontational guy
wind up being an elite cage fighter.
[inaudible] stop and think
about what, I know what, yeah.
It's, that's a very strong, I'm still
trying to wrap my mind around it. Yeah.
But I think that, um, internally
there's just a lot of,
there's a lot of expression. I, for
me, it's a, it is a big expression man.
It's an expression of just
my, my danger, my ferociousness
this, the, the, the, the,
the part of myself that I've
always held back. You know,
it's like I have to hold back. Um, I'm a
big guy, you know, like I, if I get angry,
I'm afraid I can, you know, break
something and you're like, you know what,
it's like, it's crazy. So fighting for me,
like when I train after training,
I'm super peaceful.
Right after I fight,
I feel like I've grown.
I feel like this guy is trying to hurt
me. All these things like it's, it's,
it's just a place where
we both agree like, Hey,
I'll give you my strength versus
your strength or whatever.
Whatever powers that strength is,
what will we meet in the middle?
And so it helps me balance,
man. It does. Yeah.
Because when I'm not fighting,
I'm so relaxed. It's crazy.
It makes sense. And I think that
something that could aid a lot of men.
I think just at least training,
just a speck.
I think there's something particularly
soothing about hitting a heavy bag.
There's something particular
like when you're done, man,
you feel so good when you're done
hitting pads. We've done sparring.
You feel so just peaceful.
Yeah. You got it all out.
You don't have anything left in here now.
I thought a lot of men carry a
lot of extra bullshit. Yeah, man.
Well that dash tray extra for
no reason you to let it out.
Let it out. Yeah. Some guys will
build it up in the gym. Right.
And they're super huge and it's
like, I, you gotta let it out.
But then gaining and swing those arms.
Yeah.
You'd see less of that now. It was
too, it seems like, but yeah, it just,
it would be nice if,
I really think they should teach kids
how to fight at a very early age.
That'd be cool. I think it's the opposite.
It would have the opposite effect.
I think people would fight less.
I think if you taught kids how to fight,
they would just train and spar and they
would get it all out of their system
there and they'd probably
fight a lot less. It's in,
it's kind of like in our
nature, right? Like everybody,
everybody's got curiosity. Like, I
wonder what it's like. Yeah. The,
the closest they have tutors,
the wrestling team.
You can join the wrestling team and they
will teach you a very important part of
fighting. But other than
that, like they're not going
to teach you how to fight,
but for wrestling, he's kind of like,
now at least it's kind of a loophole.
Like they don't teach
boxing in high school,
but they'll teach you how to wrestle
and that they're pretty crazy, man. Hey,
wrestling's get rough. Or it
seems like, fuck yeah, yeah, yeah.
Will the high school kids are savages.
I remember being a high school kid in a
high school wrestling room. It was awful.
And those kids were trying to kill each
other and they work at the hardest to,
yeah, run it with plates over
their head and all that stuff.
And football teams just lifting
weights and run in practice.
Those guys are doing ridiculous shit.
Slaven everybody seen that movie vision
quest, right? You saw, I've never seen it.
Never saw it. I've never seen it. Dude,
it's Matthew Modine and Matthew Modine
plays this badass wrestler and he's going
up against this dude who's this other
badass wrestler and he comes to visit the
guy while he got his training and this
dude's got a log on his back and he's
walking up stadium stairs
and they had the, he says,
you think you make the weight?
Cause he Matthew Modine's character,
she had to cut weight. And he goes,
I hope so. He goes, hope so too.
He keeps walking up the stairs like a kid.
When did this come out? Long time ago,
man. Back when Madonna was
young. Oh that's the restaurant.
So He's walking up the stadium stairs,
carrying a fucking log on to great movie,
man.
Every wrestler that I knew
when I was in high school,
everyone worship this movie.
What year did the shit come out?
It's probably like 85 or something
like the cover for it. Is it 85 Bam.
I nailed it son. Is that the
cover for it? Yes. Look at that.
I didn't even look like you have
anything to do with a wrestler.
I'd definitely would not click that
on Netflix thinking and I was around
restaurant movie at all.
She was hot as the Sun to fun times.
But yeah,
that was like the quintessential wrestling
movie because he just was dedicated.
And then there was this friend who
lied about being native American.
Is that what that is? I'm gonna say
what's that vest he's got going on.
Just wanted to be different. Stand out.
But it was a, it's a fun movie, man.
It's a fun movie. I have to
get into that for sure. Yeah.
Not a whole lot of movies about wrestling.
That's the least glamorous,
but probably toughest sport for high
school kids to get into. Definitely.
You know, that's, I stayed away
from him, you know, I tried out for,
I tried out for volleyball in high school,
actually made the team,
but my grades were terrible so I never
got to play. But I was like heavyset dude.
And I tried out. I made it. I think it
was just kind of like a joke though.
I think the coaches were just
messing with me and my friends too.
When did you get involved in martial
arts? Uh, when I was 20, so 2010.
So really quick,
right after high school I started,
um, I started traveling. So
I used to play in a band.
I used to play a mini bands and willing
guitar. I play guitar, I play drums,
I play keyboard,
a little bit of everything.
Every Christmas my mom
would just know that,
just give me a new instrument and I'd
lock myself in my room and teach myself
how to play. And that's just always
how like music was my first love,
my first love. So I taught yourself. Yeah,
I just put on headphones and I would
just match the sounds and then keep
restarting the songs over and over again.
And then if it were like a keyboard song,
I'd play it like just on
the CD player and you know,
as it evolved and for
some reason I can just,
I can match tunes with
whatever instrument it may be.
You've always been able to
do that since kid. Wow. Yeah.
So no formal training.
Nothing. That's crazy.
I've tried to take, I've tried to
take guitar lessons before, um,
but it didn't work for me and my mom
was just wasting her money like I was
learning, but it was Kinda like school
for me. Like I had a teacher, he saw me,
okay, this cord, this cord. And I was
like, Eh, like just let me feel it.
Like I gotta I gotta feel it. You know,
like I can hear it, I can, I can feel it,
I'll get it. And so I stopped going.
How many people do it like, like that?
I'm not sure. I know there's a lot of
people that can just kind of play by ear,
but so I'll like,
I just love instruments so I'll pick
anything up and just start playing it and
ended up teaching myself how to
play drums, bass guitar keyboard.
I played the standup Bass
in uh, in middle school. Um,
I've got like a little home production,
like beats studio at home, all that stuff.
So after high school I
started touring and uh,
that's when like I started
getting my heaviest.
We were eating fast food every single
day, three times a day, never drank water,
soda, only smoking like a pack
and a half of cigarettes a day.
And just on the road
traveling. And then, uh, by 19,
I got up to 305 pounds,
19 years old.
And I remember one night laying down
to go to bed and I just felt my heart
pumping bridezilla Leslie and I was
just like, no way. This is like,
I think I'm going to die.
And like I woke up in a panic and weird
thing is I got up and I went outside for
maybe like 10 minutes and I smoked
another cigarette and I was just like,
this is the problem.
Like I'm coughing up stuff my hardest
gonna give out and I'm only 19 years old,
you know?
So around that same week is when
I discovered MMA with my brother,
just like watching ultimate
fighter on TV. And so, uh,
I went on my last tour and,
uh, I told the guys like, Hey,
I'm going to go train MMA. And they're
like, oh, you're going to be a fighter,
like you think, you know? And I was just
like, I don't know what I'm going to be,
but I'm going to go train and get
healthy. And they're like, okay, cool.
We'll see you in a couple of
months, you know what I mean? Like,
no one really believed that I was going
to go and actually train and fight.
I told you, I said, well, he's been looks
as big, quiet nonconfrontational guy. So,
um,
yeah,
I went and took my first
class Moitai and March 1st,
2010 took my first Muay Thai class and
then after like a month of doing Muay
Thai,
I started to see progression.
I started to see like my face
was slimming down all this stuff.
So it gave me motivation to
keep going. And then, um,
I remember going to a MMA event amateur,
and I saw really big heavyweight
guys going at it. So I was like, ah,
I think I want to do it. I want to give
it a try. And, uh, so my coach was like,
okay, if you lose 100 pounds, I'll like,
I'll find you a fight. And I was like,
a hundred pounds. He's like, yeah,
I'll find you a fight if you
lose a hundred pounds. So, um,
I just kept training within 11 months,
lost 100 pounds,
and then took my first fight.
And then she been like,
every fight has been until now because
it's like now I have like more of a drive
and a passion for it, but all the way up
until then, everything kind of happened.
By coincidence or just like, I
just, I didn't really want to fight,
but I had a lot of people like, oh,
you're so good. Like keep doing it.
And I was the first time in my life I've
ever had people supporting me to like
really do something that was big and I
was a new guy and I was in shape and I
can, you know, girls are noticing
me now. I'm like all either,
my whole life changed within a
year of training MMA. Like wow.
From going to this guy that nobody even
paid attention to, to just like, oh, hey,
how's it going? Are you know,
like, oh, you're so in shape.
And I was just like, oh,
this is weird. It's still weird. It's
only been nine years, eight years,
you know? So everything is
still very new to me. I've only,
my first day stepping on the mat was like,
you know,
nine years ago did. That's
an amazing story. It's crazy.
That's like a legit success
story. Yeah. It's, you know, is,
is that you look at a ridiculous
ringtone. Do you have sir? Is that,
so I thought I turned it off. What
is that? It's just like stock iPhone.
I wasn't though. You ventured
into the options. Yeah.
Went down in there. Yes, sir.
Um, so yeah, that's like,
that's kind of how everything
started. And then with three, five,
three or four fights, and then I
tried out for the ultimate fighter,
so I had like three or four fights
in one year being a pro and a,
and then the ultimate fighter trials came
out and I like tried out for that and
like made it on and I was like, Oh shit.
So most of my career has been in the UFC.
Wow.
Yeah.
[inaudible].